all right Chandler's in Houston Texas
where the marriage and money event is
gonna be tonight are you going I'm not
you want to go sure I'll give you a
couple tickets if you want to go okay
I'll have to actually have a have a
group at our house tonight so we won't
be able to go oh you want take the whole
group its students I'm a student pastor
oh no marriage and money it's up to you
how many how many students it's probably
about 10 or so up do you want if you
want to take them all they'll learn
something about relationships and
they'll learn something about money I'll
give you tickets for all of them but
anyway you think about it we'll talk
about it at the end how can I help it so
recently we had some foundation or
having foundation issues at our house so
we got a bunch of quotes on that so the
quote that we are leaning towards going
with is 25,000 so the cause the cause
the foundation is pipes underground
which is 11 11 thousand so total of 36
thousand plus there's interior so into
your peers will cause good low need new
floors your now she's fallen Lynn is she
rock what that said your house is
falling in yeah sensually so we think we
call it caught it early but so that's
the work that's going to need to be done
we try to do insurance claim but they
won't cover it so in total it cost about
$40,000 and repairs we only owe 149 on a
house and so in addition to that I just
got a wreck like two weeks ago so my car
is totaled my truck is totaled and so
I'm assuming they have full liability
the other driver did so I'm assuming
that that I'll get like six Alvin back
on the truck okay so cash flow we have
seventeen an emergency fund for thirteen
seven one thousand and your emergency
fund okay all right we were saving for a
car and we have thirteen but we were
going to use that to the house and
happened before the car happened and
then any general savings we have three
total 33 it's right so you don't have
the money now there's a $40,000 repair
correct so my question is is we've been
taught we've been talking about either
pulling some equity out of the house if
so how much did we pull should we drain
I would my drive I would I would attack
this problem a different way we do it in
stages try to find two two phases that
you can do the construction in and break
it apart so you can cash flow it you've
got almost enough money the truck
doesn't throw this off you got a six
thousand dollar truck they give you a
six thousand dollar check you get
another six thousand Lord truck it does
not count in this equation you don't
upgrade your truck got totaled you just
break even all right so I know like what
foundation companies look like one of
the big expenses is like kind of the
entrance and the tunneling and stuff and
so we would have to probably do anybody
I get what's up how many bids did you
get we got 500 kind of so you've really
studied this then good yeah I know we
were having we have one more coming next
next Friday but my assumption is that
they'll be kind of on the higher end of
contractor talk to the contractor and
say listen I got thirty three so I can't
do 40 how can we break this up so I can
do half of it and now and another
portion of it later
and that's the only way you're gonna be
able to do it because I would not tell
you to borrow money for this I think
you're gonna end up being broke when
you're done anyway so you know last
thing you want to be broken in debt
further that's not a plan but I think
you can break this construction up into
two phases and get it done